ينضم الينا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوت ومن رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري عظم الله اجركم في هذا المصاب الذي
نعيشه جميعا ولربما كل يوم بتنا نشاهد هذه
المشاهد المريره التي تفطر القلب بالفعل
هشام زقوت اي وجع واي حزن تعيشونه مع
توديع كل يوم زميل شهيد صحفي بدم
[موسيقى]
بارد ليس اي صحفي وليس اي زميل وليس اي
رفيق وليس اي حبيب انه حمزه الذي كان معنا
قبل ساعات افطرنا سويا
وربما كان هناك الكثير من الحديث ولكن
قطعنا العمل فجئت الى العمل فغاب الى ذهب
الى العمل هناك اراد ان يوصل الحقيقه عن
قرب اراد ان ينقل الوجع الفلسطيني وهذه
المذبحه عن قرب بحق المدنيين الفلسطينيين
النازحين في تلك المنطقه في منطقه المواصي
الذي التي تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي انها
امنه قصف الناس هناك دمر المنازل و ذهب
حمزه لينقل الحقيقه من هناك كان هناك
استهداف قريب من تلك المنطقه فخلوا
المنطقه فلا حقهم القصف الاسرائيلي وهم
عائدون الى هنا الى المستشفى الكويتي هنا
حيث نصبنا خيمه لتكون مقرنا هنا وكان حمزه
على الدوام انا جئت بالامس فقط لازه و
التقي به واذا ب حمزه يستشهد حمزه ذهب
ليلتحق بوالدته
وباخوس شام و بابن اخته ادم عزاؤنا لابو
حمزه كيف لنا ان نصف بكل الكلمات لا يمكن
ان تصف حجم هذه الجريمه بحق الصحفيين وهي
ليست الجريمه الاولى وكما قال وائل نتمنى
ان تكون الاخيره بحق هؤلاء الصحفيين الذين
باتوا يدفعون ثمن الحقيقه وثمن نقلهم لهذا
الواقع وثمن هذه الحرب بارواحهم ان
حمزه لم يكن ذاهبا سوى لنقل هذه الحقيقه
فلحقه صاروخ اسرائيلي من طائره اسرائيليه
على سياره مدنيه فلسطينيه تكتب وعليها
اشاره بانها اشاره انها سياره تتبع
لصحفيين فلسطينيين لكن رغم كل ذلك الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهذه الطائره التي تحلق في
سماء قطاع غز الطائره الزنانه تحلق في
سماء قطاع غزه على مدار الساعه ترصد كل
شيء ترصد كل تحركات الفلسطينيين وحتى ان
طائرات الكوات كابتر باتت تدخل في منازل
الفلسطينيين تراقبهم من داخل هذه المنازل
وبالتالي هي عمليه اغتيال كانوا يعرفون ان
حمزه الدحدوح والزميل مصطفى ثريا وان بحول
وبجانبهم عشرات من الصحفيين الذين ذهبوا
لتغطيه هذه الجريمه وهذه المجزره
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي كان يستهدف هو من
هذا القصف الاسرائيلي هؤلاء الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين فاستشهد حمزه واستشهد الزميل
مصطفى ثريه الذي كان ايضا ذاهبا في مهمه
لصالح الجزيره وهو ربما من اهم الصحفيين
في غزه الذين يصورون بطائرات بالطائرات
الم المسيره للدرون من السماء لينقل لنا
من السماء حجم هذه الجريمه حجم الجرائم
بحق الصحفيين وبحق المواطنين الفلسطينيين
في غزه لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو
لم يعجبه تغطيه مصطفى ثريا وحمزه الدحدوح
الذين كانوا يغطوا عن قرب كانوا يذهبون
الى اماكن القصف كانوا يخاطرون بحياتهم من
اجل ان ينقلوا الصوره لكن في الايام
الاخيره رجونا رجونا ان لا يذهبوا الى
الاماكن التي تقصف كان القصف ربما منذ
ساعات عدت عليه ساعات وبالتالي لذلك ذهبوا
الى هذه المنطقه الانسانيه التي طلب الجيش
الاسرائيلي من هؤلاء السكان ان يذهبوا
اليها قصفهم فارادوا ان ينقلوا ان ينقلوا
فقط واقع ينقل الحقيقه هم صوروا وهم
عائدون من هذا التصوير لاحقهم القصف
الاسرائيلي فاستهدف هذه السياره المدنيه
فقص فهم فاستشهد حمزه واستشهد مصطفى
ونترحم على حمزه والى اللقاء يا حمزه